[Música]
bienvenidos a ellos hoy en france 24 en
octubre se conoció la denuncia contra un
hombre en filadelfia eeuu o por violar a
una mujer tras acusarla y abusar las
formas de 40 minutos en un tren lleno de
gente a las afueras de la ciudad ningún
pasajero llamó al 911 al contrario
algunos registraron la agresión en sus
celulares más de 20 paradas después un
empleado del tren contactó a la policía
vamos a conversar del caso y del crimen
de abuso sexuales con una experta en
derechos reproductivos en eeuu pero
antes vamos a la historia
el 18 de octubre las autoridades en los
suburbios de la ciudad más grande de
pensilvania informaron sobre el episodio
ocurrido en un tren de cercanías a las
afueras de la ciudad la policía dijo que
un extraño violento a la víctima por más
de 40 minutos y en presencia de otros
pasajeros que deberían haber hecho algo
hay algún indicio a través de las redes
sociales u otras vistas para su
departamento de que alguien en el tren
lo filmó aquí
les puedo decir que la gente sostenía su
teléfono en la dirección de esta mujer
siendo atacado fue un empleado de
tránsito de un tren quien alertó que
algo no estaba bien con una mujer que
estaba a bordo la profesora de
psicología en el john jay college de
justicia criminal en la ciudad de nueva
york señaló la escena como preocupante y
como un infrecuente ejemplo del llamado
efecto espectador el fenómeno de dicta
que cuantas más personas estén presentes
en un crimen es más probable que sientan
que es responsabilidad de alguien más
intervenir
es preocupante esta línea con muchas de
las investigaciones que históricamente
se han demostrado sobre los efectos de
los espectadores cuando tenemos varias
personas las personas no necesariamente
intervienen sin embargo una
investigación más reciente sugiere que
al ver imágenes de vídeos de
circunstancias más extremas hasta en el
90% de los casos vemos a personas
interviniendo por lo en este caso fue
una aberración que alguien nos diera un
paso adelante para ayudar
en el vídeo de vigilancia quedó
capturado todo el episodio y un hombre
de 35 años fue arrestado y acusado
para el análisis está con ellos hoy
alejandra cárdenas directora de
estrategias globales legales del centro
de derechos reproductivos en nueva york
alejandra bienvenida y qué opina usted
de esa teoría del buy standard efecto el
efecto espectador la gente vio la
agresión de principio a fin pero no hizo
nada bueno la verdad es que es
fácticamente es más cruel en la gente si
haga algo a que nadal lo que la gente
suele hacer es llamar llamar a la
policía llamar al número de emergencia
entonces no es cierto que la mayoría de
las veces la gente ve que se está
cometiendo un crimen incluso pues
crímenes contra mujeres o niñas y no
hace nada lo que sí es raro es que la
gente intervenga física que alguien se
lance y vamos a entrar a separar al
perpetrador de la víctima eso es más
estadísticamente menos común y pues
existe embargo espero pero
yo creo que no podemos analizar el vice
ayer te vi ninguna de estas pero menos
sin entender que este es un caso de
violencia sexual y es un caso de
violencia género es decir es una mujer
que está siendo violada
y eso es importante porque primero
porque las mujeres porque si habían
mujeres en los bajos en el vagones en
particular de pasajeros de ese tremendo
estaba ocurriendo el hecho la mayoría de
las mujeres tienen
mucho miedo a intervenir porque sienten
que ellas también van a poder ser
abusadas o sea psicológicamente está
mostrado que en esos casos hay como un
twitter
como ese activa algo en el cerebro de
las mujeres el deshacer pánico porque la
mayoría de las mujeres vivimos bajo una
amenaza latente de poder ser violadas
ahora lo que ocurre con los con los
hombres que están en el 35
digamos que eso es parte de una
conversación más difícil pero más
importante que dar si queremos realmente
resolver empezará a salir
este problema y este tipo de violencia
que es la cultura la vibración porque
finalmente y eso pasa en eeuu y pasan
todo el mundo vivimos en culturas donde
a las niñas se les enseña nos fijamos
nos obsesionamos mucho como sociedad en
enseñarle a las niñas desde pequeñas a
que no se violan a que tengan cuidado
pero nunca le enseñamos a los niños
almanza y menos les enseñamos a hablar e
intervenir cuando un compañero es
haciendo un chiste sobre violación
cuando un compañero empieza a tocar a
una niña claramente sin su
consentimiento bueno vamos a seguir
hablando precisamente de las personas
que iban en el tren e las personas que
grabaron lo podrían ser procesadas
porque es un delito ser testigo de
abusos y no denunciar los que tanto un
abuso es responsabilidad de quienes
están alrededor de ese crimen
bueno en este caso yo creo que va a ser
muy difícil que no se quede el caso a
juicio y que no se condene al
responsable constante porque entonces
todo está registrado en los vídeos de
las cámaras de seguridad pero en
términos de la responsabilidad de los
demás pasajeros lo que yo entiendo es
que en realidad
es muy poco probable que sean
se les imputa algún delito por no haber
intervenido es más grave que se les
imputen delitos a las personas que están
filmando o tomando fotos de lo que está
ocurriendo porque bueno eso ya entrar
ser parte de otro tipo de violaciones de
esas mismas personas
a la víctima a la integridad personal
etcétera de la persona que está haciendo
abusados un momento porque necesarias
imágenes alcanzaron a ser compartidas
pero pero ya no hay como un sistema no
hay un buen sistema digamos de
responsabilidad
en términos de obligarlo por lo menos
aquí a
intervenir
entonces lo que yo he discutido con
colegas
aquí es que
sean imputadas por ese hecho es posible
llamar en este caso nos da la
oportunidad para tener una perspectiva
de la víctima hablemos lo que pasa con
una persona que sufre una violación o
cuál es el proceso interno y sobre todo
el daño para una persona que es
violentada con un crimen que es
comparado con el asesinato
no pues por supuesto es como uno de los
episodios de violencia más atroces que
puede sufrir un ser humano está
demostrado que altera por completo
la concepción de sí mismo la
reconciliación de ser dueña del cuerpo
de uno mismo de disfrutar de la
sexualidad sea rompe en muchos sentidos
esos lazos que mantiene con otros seres
humanos que definitivamente están pues
pasados por el afecto indignas en la
fisicalidad no entonces es realmente
pues aparte de boyante que puede existir
el riesgo de que uno que embarazada o
por una violación y que le pasión
enfermedad de transmisión sexual
entonces realmente en la magnitud y la
variedad de los daños que puede
ocasionar
una violación sexual pues es enorme y
tomamos muchos años a veces toda una
vida de digamos de mucha ayuda y mucha
contención emocional psicológica que
para poder hacer un poco de sanación
vamos a superar superar elegimos
yo creo que es importante también hablar
de
digamos de la justicia
que tanto se logrará la justicia en
estos casos
por lo menos aquí en eeuu
que mucha gente tiene la idea de que
esas cosas acá digamos no pasan son un
poco mejores en latinoamérica o en otros
países del sur global pero lo cierto es
que en eeuu cada 68 segundos se estima
que una persona es abusada sexualmente
violada específicamente y
estadísticamente de cada cinco mujeres
una va a ser violada en algún momento de
su vida y ese es el crimen en una
portada estas son estadísticas teniendo
en cuenta que este es el crimen menos
reportado todos y lo peor es que nos
sorprende este caso para terminar es una
confirmación más de que las mujeres no
podemos en las condiciones actuales es
sentirnos seguras ni tampoco apropiarnos
del espacio público usted qué opina
o sea desafortunadamente no se sabe qué
o digamos es masculinizado y está
regido por la masculina más tóxica y las
mujeres en efecto pues somos
advertidas digamos que cuando ambos
estamos nos atrevemos a habitar este
espacio pues eso quiere decir que
estamos básicamente que tenemos que
aceptar que eso viene con un costo no es
muy complicado y acá en eeuu cada tanto
hay como un
un llamado a las mujeres sobre todo más
jóvenes a reclamar ese espacio público
hay una marcha que cada tanto ocurre es
anual que aquí le llaman la marcha de
las y es una forma como de
desafiar ese estereotipo no como hace si
ellos vienen a calles porque no bueno
que por por supuesto es horrible contra
las mujeres que ejercen el trabajo
sexual que también puede ser víctimas de
violencia sexual pero este esta idea
despectiva que de que es una persona que
está así que pidiendo que le hagan daño
y yo creo que la verdad es que pues más
que las más que las leyes más que la
policía porque la policía también está
demostrado que es en muchos casos
perpetradores de violencia contra las
mujeres más que el estado policía en lo
que tenemos que apostar porque es lo
único que va a resolver esto es a un
cambio cultural y eso empieza con estar
hablando de estas cosas estar diciendo
ya los hombres de nuestra vida los
hombres que con quién tenemos contacto
que bueno que asuman su responsabilidad
y su responsabilidad no es sólo que
nunca han violado muy bien pero con
llegado y compañero este que hace cuando
escucha a sus amigos haciendo un chiste
piense que usted hacía cuando era
adolescente y sus amigos haciendo cosas
abusivas tales yo creo que sólo cuando
revisamos esa responsabilidad y los
hombres en hacer daño y decimos que
ponerla en las mujeres de cuidarnos
es cuando vamos a lograr realmente que
podamos habitar el espacio público en
condiciones de igualdad
y para eso para eso estamos aquí en ella
soy alejandra cárdenas del centro de
derechos reproductivos en nueva york que
gracias a usted y a nuestros
televidentes sigan en france24 nos vemos
próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]